I realized in assembly theory that the
universe is too big to contain
itself and and I think this is and now
coming back and I want to I want to kind
of change your mind about time because
I'm I'm guessing that you're a time is
just um coordinate yeah so I'm I'm going
to change your guessing you're one of
those yeah I'm going to change your one
of those I'm going change your mind in
real time or at least attempt oh in real
time there you go um I already got the
tattoo so this is going to be
embarrassing if you Chang my mind but
you can just add you can just add an
arrow time onto it right true or erase
it a bit so um and the argument that I
think that is really most interesting is
like people say the initial
conditions um specify the future of the
universe okay fine let's say that's the
case for a moment now let's go back to
newtonium
mechanics now the uncertainty but
principle in newtonium mechanics is this
if I give you the coordinates of your of
an object moving in
space and the coordinates of another
object and they Collide in space and you
know those initial conditions you should
know exactly what's going to happen
however you cannot specify these
coordinates to infinite Precision now
everyone said you know oh this is kind
of like you know um the chaos Siri
argument no no it's deeper than that
here's a problem with numbers this how
this is where Hilbert and Brower fell
out um
to have the coordinates of this object a
given object are colliding you have to
have them to infinite Precision that's
what Hilbert says it says no problem
infinite Precision is fine let's just
take that for granted but when the
object is finite and it can't store its
own coordinates what' you do
MH so in principle if a finite object
cannot be specified to infinite
Precision in principle the initial
conditions don't apply well how do you
know it can't store its uh well how do
you store an infinitely long number in a
finite size
well we're using Infinity very Loosely
here no no we're using infinite
Precision I mean not Loosely but very
precisely so you think infinite
Precision is required well let's let's
take the object let's say the object is
uh a golf ball mhm golf ball is a few
centimet in diameter we can work out how
many atoms are in the golf ball and
let's say we can store numbers down to
Atomic dislocations mhm so we can work
out how many atoms there are in the golf
ball and we can store the coordinates in
that golf ball down to that number but
beyond that we can't let's make the golf
ball
smaller and and the this is where I
think that we think that we get
Randomness in quantum mechanics and some
people say you can't get Randomness
quantum mechanics deterministic but ah
this is where this is where we realize
that classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics suffer from the same
uncertainty principle and that is the
inability to specify the the initial
conditions to a precise enough degree to
give you determinism the universe is
intrinsically too big and that's why
time exists it's non-deterministic
looking back into the past you can look
at the you can use logical um arguments
because you can say was it true or false
you already know but this is the fact we
are unable to predict the future with
the Precision is not evidence of lack of
knowledge it's evidence the universe is
generating new
things okay so to you first of all
quantum mechanics you can just say
statistically what's going to happen
when two golf balls hit each other
statistically but that but but sure I
can say statistic what's going to happen
but then what they do happen yeah and
and and you keep nesting it together you
can't I mean it goes almost back to look
at look at look at um let's think about
entropy in the universe so how do you
what how do we how do we understand um
entropy change well we could do the look
at or process we can use the aeric
hypothesis um we can also have um um um
we can also have the uh counterfactuals
where we have all the different states
and we could even put that in the
Multiverse right but both those are kind
of they they're they're non- physical
M the Multiverse kind of collapses back
to the same problem about the Precision
so all the the what you if you accept
you don't have to have true and false
going forward into the future um the
real numbers are real they're just
they're just they're observables we're
trying to see exactly where time being
fundamental sneaks in and this
difference between that the the the golf
ball can't
contain its own
position perfectly
precisely if how that leads to time
needing to be fundamental let me I have
a what do you believe do you believe or
do you accept you have free
will yeah I think at this moment in time
I believe that I have free will so then
you are then you have to believe that
time is
fundamental I understand that's the St
you've made well no that we can
logically because if you don't have free
will so like if you're in a if you're in
a universe that has no time universe is
deterministic if it's deterministic then
you have no free will I I think the
space of how much we don't know is so
vast that saying the universe is
deterministic that from that jumping
there's no free will is just too
difficult of a leap no I logically
follows no no I I don't disagree it's
not I'm not saying any I mean it's deep
and it's important all I'm all I'm
saying and it's the difference of it's
actually different to what I've said
before is that if you don't require
platonistic
mathematics and accepts that that
non-determinism is how the universe
looks and that gives us our creativity
and the way the universe is getting
novelty it's kind of really deeply
important in assembly Theory because
assembly Theory starts to actually give
you a mechanism why you go from boring
time which is basically initial
conditions specify everything to a Mis
in Creative time and I hope we'll do
experiments I think it's really
important to I would love to do an
experiment that prove that time is
fundamental and the universe is
generating
novelty um I don't know all the features
of that experiment yet but by you know
having these conversations openly and
getting people to think about the
problems in a new way better people more
intelligent people with good
mathematical backgrounds can say oh hey
I've got an idea I would love to do an
experiment that that shows that the
Universe I mean universe is too too big
for itself going forward in time and and
I really you know this is why I I really
hate the idea of the boltzman brain the
boltzman brain makes me super kind of
like you know everyone's having a free
lunch it's like saying it's like let's
break all the laws of physics so a
boltzman brain is this idea that in a
long enough Universe a brain will just
emerge in the universe as conscious
without and that neglects the causal
change of evolution that required to
produce that brain and this is where the
computational argument really falls down
because the computation is can say I can
calculate the probability of a bolts and
brain M and I can and they'll give you
probability but I can calculate
probability of a bolts and brain zero
just because the the the space of
possibilities is so large yeah it's like
when we start falling ourselves with
numbers that we can't actually measure
and we can't ever conceive of I think it
I think it it it it it doesn't give us a
good explanation and I've become I want
to explain why life is in the universe I
think life is actually novelty minor not
I mean life basically Minds novelty
almost from the future and makes it
actualizes in the
present okay life is a novelty
minor uh from the future that is
actualized in the present
yeah I think so novelty minor first of
all
novelty what's the origin of novelty
when you go from boring time to creative
time where is that is it as simple as as
Randomness like you're referring to um I
I am really struggling with Randomness
because I had a really good argument
with Yasha bark about Randomness he said
Randomness doesn't give you free will
that's insane because You' just be
random but I think and I think he's
right at that level yeah but I don't
think we I don't think he is right on
another level and it's not about
Randomness it's about it's about
constrained going to sound like
constrained opport I'm making this up as
I go along so making this up constrained
opportunity so what I mean is like so
you have to have so that the novelty
what is novelty you know this is why I
think is a funny thing you ever want to
discuss AI why I think everyone's kind
of gone AI mad is that they
misunderstanding um no no y but let's
think about novelty ask what is novelty
so I think novelty is a genuinely new
configuration that is not predicted by
the P past right and that you discover
in the present right and um that is
truly different right now everyone says
that some people say that novelty
doesn't exist it's always with precedent
I want to do experiments that show that
that is not the case and it goes back to
a question you asked me a a few moments
ago which is where is the Factory yeah
right CU I think the same mechanism that
gives us a factory gives us novelty and
I think that that is that is why I'm so
deeply hung up on time I mean of course
I'm wrong but how wrong and I and I
think that that life opens up that
commentarial space in a way that the the
our current laws of physics or the what
as contrived in a deterministic initial
condition universe even with the get out
of the Multiverse David deuts style
which I love by the way but I don't
think is
correct um but it's it's it's kind it's
really
beautiful Multiverse the the David
Deutsch's conception of the Multiverse
is kind of like given um but I think the
the problem with wave particle duality
and quantum mechanics is not um about
the Multiverse it's about understanding
how determined the past is well I don't
think just think that actually this is a
a discussion I was having with Sarah
about that right where she was like oh I
think we we' been debating this for a
long time now um about how we how do we
reconcile
novelty determinism
indeterminism so okay just to clarify
you both you and Sarah think the
universe is not
deterministic uh I'm I won't speak for
Sarah but I roughly I I think that the
universe I think the universe is
deterministic looking back in the P back
in the past right but undetermined going
F going forward in the future so I'm
kind of having my cake and eat it eating
it here this is because I fundamentally
don't understand Randomness right as
Yasha told me or other people told me
but if I adopt a new view now which
um the new view is the universe is just
non-deterministic but I'd like to refine
that and say the universe appears
deterministic going back in the past but
it's but it's undetermined going forward
in the future so how can we have a
determinist a universe that has
deterministically looking rules that's
non-determined going in the future it's
this breakdown in Precision in the
initial conditions and we have to just
stop using initial conditions and start
looking at
trajectories and how how um the comori
space behaves in expanding Universe in
time and space an assembly Theory helps
us quantify the transition to biology
and biology appears to be novelty mining
cuz it's making crazy stuff you know um
that that we are unique to earth right
there are objects on Earth that are
unique to Earth they will not be found
anywhere else because you can do the
commentor math uh what was that
statement you made about life is novelty
mining from the future yeah what's the
what's what's the little element of time
that you're introducing this so what I'm
kind of meaning is cuz the future is
bigger than the present in a determin IC
Universe how do you go from the how do
how do the how do the states go from one
to another I mean there's a mismatch
right yeah so so that must mean that you
have a little bit of indeterminism
whether that's Randomness or something
else I don't understand I want to do
experiments to formulate a theory to
refine that as we go forward that might
help us explain that and um and I think
is why I'm so um determined to try and
crack the the non-life toli transition
looking at at networks and molecules
that might help us think about it the
mechanism but certainly the future is
bigger than the past in in my conception
of the universe and some conception of
the universe and by the way that's not
obvious right that's where was just kind
of the future being bigger than the
past well that that's one statement and
the statement that the universe is not
big enough to contain the future is
another statement yeah yeah yeah yeah
that one is a big one I that one's a
really big one I think so I think but I
think it's entirely
because look we have the second law and
right now I mean I'm we don't need the
second law if the future's bigger than
the past it follows naturally right so
why are we retrofitting all these these
sticking plasters onto our reality to
hold on to a Timeless Universe yeah but
that's because it's kind of difficult to
imagine the universe
that's they can't contain the future but
isn't that really exciting it's very
exciting but it's
it's hard uh I mean we're we're humans
on Earth and we have a very kind
of four dimensional conception of the
world of 3D plus time it's just hard to
Intuit it a world where what does that
even mean a universe that can't contain
the
future yeah it's kind of it's kind of
crazyd obvious weird I mean I suppose it
sounds obvious yeah if it's true but the
nice thing is you can so what I I mean
so the reason why assembly Theory turned
me onto that was that you let's let's
just start in the present and look at
all the complex molecules and go
backwards in time and understand how
evolutionary processes go gave rise to
them it's not in it's not at all obvious
the taxo which is a complex one of the
most complex natural products produced
by biology was going to be invented by
biology it's a accident you know taxo is
unique to Earth there's no taxo
elsewhere in the universe and taxo was
not decided by the initial conditions it
was decided by this kind of the this
interplay between the so the past simply
is embedded in the present it gives some
features but why the past doesn't map to
the Future one to one is because the
universe is too big to contain itself
that gives space for creativity novelty
and and un some things which are
unpredictable